hi everyone I'm David Griffin and I'm
Michael Medina here to talk about arrow
season 2 episode 13 heir to the demon
Talia our boat Nisa long run Nason
closely cool in the Black Canary Sarah
little lesbian couple that's okay you
know other times okay we can do that oh
yes for their yeah hopefully if you
watch her no we like what everything so
lutely no um so that was that was a big
news so let's have a maybe so well this
let's talk first about Nisa as a whole
let's talk about what Christina law what
do you think about when she first came
on screen there um I loved her dramatic
entrance first the bed sheets all the
bed rolling in the bed she then just
calming down kitties whosoever person
wrote it was good and I really liked her
she was believable yeah you know I
thought later on in the episode of a
fight sequence with Oliver was well done
yeah you know um yeah I really like her
I like her look right you know and I
just got excited the possibility of
maybe seeing some ratios however you
want to pronounce it right and maybe
some Talia because I remember your first
what are you first saucer watch the
episode Mike said that you know why
she'd make a good Talia yeah she look
yeah I mean absolutely bring Thailand
which interesting forgot if somebody
called me out last week said I jumped
around too much led to do two episodes
in one video that's kind of hard to do
I'm kind of bring this back here let's
say why do you lie so let's talk about
some of the possibilities with the whole
Ra's al Ghul dilemma here we know a
dilemma it's a good thing we know that
he's he's around he's in his universe so
he could make an appearance he could not
cuz I'm with the fact that it was ending
at the M skipping all the way to the
very end is that she said he said I
release you yeah unlike the she's not
that power yes all the power she did say
she did it in the name the day I look
like I don't know but that still counts
earned right no but what not but um also
since we're talking about the end right
now it'll be interesting to see how
Slade plays into all this because I feel
like there's got to be some kind of a
connection right brother blood and Slade
and race right you know and how that all
that's going to come together so it's
gonna be interesting because I feel like
these last few few episodes a big teased
Slade this episode actually didn't have
any flashbacks to the island I mean the
clash but I mean yeah which made sense
cuz you already
what's going to lees recipe episode with
pops cooking dinner this little April a
happier time yeah I was happier times
but yeah they've been teasing Slade a
lot which so you figure at some point
there's got to be a payoff we're gonna
see we got a couple weeks back a glimpse
of his suit yep yeah which is really
cool so I'm looking forward to seeing
that um all in all I did think this was
a strong episode I know a few weeks back
I did say their first episode after
their break was a little weaker and a
lot of you guys also felt the same way
um I felt this was a little bit stronger
his back on track um I did have while
watching this episode there were a few
things that I thought of that don't
necessarily pertain just to this episode
I'll get to those in a moment but it's I
love the chemistry between like it again
like with nisa with Oliver maybe you
could even with Nissa and Sara cuz i
mean i don't know like really don't
criticize anybody but it's like you know
you have lesbians this is CW it's like
of course are gonna be gorgeous not that
there aren't look we're now lay here
there's beautiful couples of men and
women and everybody mixed together it's
fine but it's like see them to get a
little corny you know of course not he
hot girls making out it's like or so but
it was believable way good actress is
doing good job delivering their you know
their dialogue it was believable and I
really like the scenes um with Oliver
his mom more of who's now running for
mayor um what thoughts maybe the most
mysterious character of everyone
absolutely is what is her motivation
what is her endgame she knows she knows
Ross he knows the League of Assassins
she has even more power than maybe even
Malcolm Merlyn does it's like what's her
what's her game was interesting
characters who because I'd mentioned
this before how um there are moments
when you want to sympathize with her
like when she was in prison you felt bad
for her you won't almost were like
rooting for her and then now it's like
well she [ __ ] yes I should I hate
should I not like her because we do get
the reveal at least to Oliver you know
that if she is in fact she lied to him
that Malcolm is Thea's daddy we all knew
that of course yeah but you know that
was a big reveal for him and he
basically said you know and in front in
my as far as like the public is
concerned I'm there for you but uh her
private life I'm done and also too we
see again I mean I have to call this out
justice
out of the way Diggle again for the
umpteenth week in a row has done nothing
and that's when the problems I've had
with the show because he's certainly
capable people all those quoting
everything he came in so look I got the
lab reports here yeah oh gee well done
digging like good guys this week his
giant jobs over yeah but he's capable of
it like getting out there going on
missions with them you know what I mean
and we really haven't seen that he's
just kind of like a gopher you know he
pretty much like goes and i'll look into
it and then that's it you know it's also
get out of there um another problem i
had though i was watching this episode i
first thought it last week I'm with
Moira running for mayor I don't know how
believable that is yes the last season
she was part of this whole life and row
here is going up half of Starling city
you mean to tell me she's the only
person in all of Starling city that
would be like you know what this works
right we wanted to run for Mia right
this works I like her so I don't know if
I believe that I mean again it goes like
it's it's a roller coaster with more
yeah you know what I mean so it'll be
interesting to see what they do with her
and of course you know everybody likes
we got to have a little bit about
olicity olicity olicity you know it's
good some great moments been Oliver and
Felicity of course in the end Oliver oh
he's working out scary hit the bag I got
the CW cheesy romantic music on got a
shirt off you know Sarah comes up and
sparks you know magic a magic happens
gotta go down scoop Lizzie yeah so maybe
Felicio olicity won't happen i don't
know maybe well maybe you know i mean it
is TV you want to stretch something like
this out I mean with a show like arrow
with so much going on it's like why rush
into something like that so I think it's
still possible you know like you know
maybe next year who knows yeah you know
there's there just a lot going on this
this this series so much to me Roy
though I was a little districts reveal
that you know now he knows what's going
on I was looking forward to this
particular episode to see ok well now
like his first steps is trying to be a
sidekick we didn't get that which is
okay because you know sometimes I like
Roy and I like the actor that plays them
tend to overact a little bit just a bit
intense but you know you know I want to
mention just cuz last week's review
there a lot of comments talking about
how or somebody pretty perfect comment
about how summer Klaus character hasn't
been around where's she been she's been
gone for a while I think she's gonna
play a role towards the end I don't know
she's gonna beat Olly especially after
seeing you know Nisa but I mean I think
she is gonna play an integral role I
think towards the end I think maybe
hopefully she'll be around in season 3
chosen getting canceled because poor
summer glau she canceled when she's
around but now something's awesome so
you hold out in the right way to do that
shows like a castle the ratings are too
high but we need to see a little bit
more of her in Malcolm Merlyn still
lingering out there's okay we'll see
more of him but maybe in a future
episode and again I think that just goes
back to like what we were saying is
there's so much going on and stuff why
rush it you know what I mean I mean this
is a show that's full of surprises so
could she be Thalia she could be too
could be in the Prince Abu point out
she's a character from the book so
exactly exactly but as we know like with
film and television they tend to bend
things are a bit here and I just make
things fit so I'm open for it right so I
mean that's what you know that's what I
can I thought about this week's episode
another exciting episode so much going
on the one of the al Ghul family has
joined the the group and hopefully
she'll be around more i'm sure cochino
while we'll see much more of her so yeah
you know as always yo come chat with us
let us know what you thought about this
week's episode and all the craziest
point out the easter eggs and i'm sure
mike and i miss a few of those is just
too much going on you can come find us
on think you're calm or on this YouTube
page think hero pro yeah we're also on
Twitter dennis michael myself want to
come chat with us about our favorite
shows bug dennis about why he's not
watching the show you know me to get out
that's at think hero i'm at griffin de
and i'm at mr. michael Alexis and we
also have a Facebook page which is
facebook.com slash think your fans and
please you know like hit the subscribe
button spread the word all the goodness
about TV movies everything I think he
was talking about and as always see you
next week
you